you know when you're uh like you're in a
bar yeah and
somebody you know bumps into you or
whatever
and you like hey what's your problem and
they go into like a legitimate fight
stance
you know what I'm saying sure yeah like
instantly you know oh this dude trains
so it went from hey I'm Echo and I'm
kind of tough and I'm gonna Jack this
dude up too oh man and then imagine what
you know so he goes into like a
legitimate fight stance hands up you
know he's kind of looking light on his
feet and you're like oh I wasn't
anticipating this and then
you like take a swing at him
and he just like slips your and cracks
you
and cracks you again and so you're a
little bit stunned and you realize you
just messed with someone that's a
well-trained